one of the things that con artists do
incredibly well is actually read other
people so psychics psychics are kind of
the ultimate at this they can read all
of the cues that you're throwing off
without realizing you're throwing them
off and so they seem psychic to you even
though you're telling them everything
you're giving them everything that they
need to go on and the truth is most of
us don't do that most of us really do
not listen to other people
Victor Lustig who's one of the most
famous con artists of the 20th century
his nickname was count Lustig and he
sold the Eiffel Tower two times for
scrap metal he said and neither time was
he reported because the people who had
bought the Tower were so incredibly just
embarrassed that they didn't want to say
anything that's how he was able to pull
it off twice and live to tell the tale
he wrote something called the ten
commandments of the con artists and one
of the commandments is a con artist
isn't a good talker a con artist is a
good listener and I think that that
tells you everything that you need to
know con artists are people who actually
listen they listen when you talk they
pay attention we don't do that normally
when we ask a question we don't really
listen to the answer we're half there
we're half thinking about what we're
going to say next we're thinking about
ourselves we're not thinking about the
other person maybe we're even on our
phone checking something while they're
while they're talking you say oh yeah I
can multitask don't worry keep going no
you can't you're not actually listening
to them and so you're missing all of
these cues the thing that makes us
better able to read other people is
being motivated motivation really
enhances our ability to look at other
people and see what they're telling us
it forces us to listen con artists are
motivated to listen because that's their
livelihood they need to read you well in
order to sell you what they're selling
you and most of us don't have that mode
Bishan and so if we do if we figure out
a way you know this is actually
important to me I want to invest in this
friendship I want to really understand
this person I want to be the kind of
people who really is a good friend who
really pays attention if we motivate
ourselves then all of a sudden we can
settle we can sometimes pick up the cues
like you know how are you sitting what's
your posture like what's your voice like
do you look like you've slept have you
you know have you changed anything about
your appearance how often do you change
your hair or change something and nobody
notices there's this wonderful story of
a news anchor who came in wearing the
exact same thing every single day just
to see if anyone would notice and no one
did and he was male so that was a little
bit easy it's a little bit of a cheat
you just wear a shirt in the suit and
everyone says okay and a woman I don't
think would have been able to pull it
off quite as well and yet sometimes
women complain that husbands don't she
don't notice a change of color or you
know totally new outfit that they're
just not paying attention to those sorts
of things
motivation it's just hard it's just hard
to keep yourself motivated all the time
to pay attention to people unless you're
a psychic and you know that reading that
person well will enable you to have them
come back because then they'll believe
that you're a real psychic because they
were able to extract a lot of
information from you that by the way is
is another one of the skills it's not
just observing it's being able to
extract information so being a good
listener people can tell when you're
listening and when they can tell that
someone is really listening they start
talking you know you start talking more
and more when you feel like someone is
actually listening to what you're saying
and all of a sudden you're telling
things about yourself that you never
thought you were going to be telling